jack barrett not a disappointment for
the tampa bay buccaneers and shaq
barrett was on with dan patrick early
today here is do we have the sound or we
don't have the sound here is shaq
barrett uh talking about his decision to
stay with the
bucks it pretty much was tampa and time
planning time it was given type of every
opportunity to uh
to keep me here and to make it work and
it uh it worked out perfectly so i
really didn't want to have to leave and
go anywhere else to be honest that's why
i said it from the jump that tampa was
my plan a
and i'm happy that i had to get to plan
b
this confirms my suspicion peter that
jason light the gm of the buccaneers
gave shaq barrett an offer and said as
of noon monday if you don't take it
there's plenty of pass rushers out there
we have to go get somebody else so it's
there
and as a clock what happened clock
strikes 12 within minutes shaq barrett
staying in tampa because oh and what a
shock
any offers that came in before the
beginning of the negotiating window and
we all know that they do they weren't
better than what the buccaneers were
offering
but here's the other part of this at
least the way i look at it and look i
would have done exactly what jason light
uh and his aide mike greenberg have done
in tampa
and that obviously bruce arians wants to
do
i would bring
the band back
but
i just want to caution i want to throw
some cold water
on this notion that
bringing
everybody back
is absolutely categorically the best
idea for your team
we don't know if it's the best idea for
your team
everybody was so aligned and so
perfectly happy
in in 2020 when tom brady came in and
when i asked the question in in august
to cameron great there's only going to
be one football how are you guys all
going to get along he goes if you'd been
around here for the losing that we've
had and what a bummer it was to be
around here on so many sundays believe
me you're not going to care about your
stats
so i agree i and and they they showed
that this year
good for them
how will it work in year two after you
have that ring
and and i'm not i'm not looking to
to you know throw a wet blanket on this
i'm just simply saying that bringing
everybody back certainly does not
guarantee a second championship
and peter i've always been a believer
the team that wants to repeat should go
find a veteran who doesn't have a super
bowl ring who really wants one who can
come in and just kind of
restart that engine and get guys to not
be complacent but you know what you got
tom brady whose mission is to get more
however many more is if it's seven then
it's eight if it's eight then it's nine
and that's why i think for for any other
team the idea of keeping the band
together yeah you can get complacent you
can get soft you can get fat you can get
lazy you can get you can get
uh satisfied you can lose your edge
you're going out to climb the same
mountain you've already climbed once
what's the big deal what's the
attraction we just climbed that damn
mountain with tom brady i think that's
what changes it because he's going to
continue to have that force of
personality that is going to keep
everyone on the same page that is going
to drive them the way he was driven by
bill belichick and that's why i think
for them it works because of brady any
other team i agree with you a thousand
percent you're it's impossible to think
you're going to get back there with
brady you can't say it is not the way
he's performed over the years
oh i i agree with you mike i just don't
think it's a lock that uh you know
everybody goes to vegas and puts a
thousand on the bucks repeating i it's
just not a lock and the reason that
brady is so valuable for everybody out
there who's listening and who thinks
what a cliche it is here's why it's
valuable late in the year devon white is
having one of the best years of any
linebacker in the nfl and he finds out
he is not getting into the pro bowl and
when you're 22 years old and you've
grown up you're a huge nfl fan you want
to go to the pro bowl even though there
isn't going to be a pro bowl but you
want to get named to the team and he's
sulking about it one day and brady comes
by and he goes hey
who cares about the pro bowl we're in
this for another bowl a bigger bowl
and devin white immediately thought
what an idiot i am
you know and and it's that's such a
selfish way to look at it that i need to
be in this for the super bowl brady's
right so that is what brady does
especially the young players on the team
yep and i think he'll be doing that
again all year long in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports